ادواتها السودانيون سلطه عيد الفطر
المبارك وسط تصاعدي حده الاشتباكات بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في اكثر من
مدينه ومنطقه في العاصمه الخرطوم حيث
تتركز المواجهات ادت مجموعات من السكان
صلاه العيد في عدد من المساجد والساحات
العامه في المدن الثلاثه الخرطوم والخرطوم
بحري واندرمان وتعذرت اقامه صلاه العيد في
عده احياء في العاصمه بسبب التدهور الامني
واستمرار القذف المتبادل بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع اخبرنا النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الوضع في الولايات بدا مختلفا لاسيما في
المناطق التي خفت فيها حده المواجهات او
تلك التي لم تشهد مواجهات اصلا في مدينه
بورسودان ثاني اكبر مدن البلاد والواقعه
على البحر الاحمر ادى السكان صلاه العيد
في مواقع عده
[موسيقى]
وفي ولايه النيل الازرق جنوبيا البلاد ادت
جموع من المواطنين صلاه العيد في احدى
الساحات العامه بمدينه الدمازين عاصمه
الولايه واتناول خطيب الصلاه الاوضاع
الراهنه في البلاد داعيا طرفي الصراع الى
وقف الاقتتال
[موسيقى]